Il y a quelques semaines, des chercheurs anglais
ont réussi à reproduire la voix d’un scribe,
momifié depuis 3 000 ans.
Pour cela, ils ont reconstitué son canal vocal,
une partie de l’organisme qui va de la glotte aux lèvres.
Et voilà ce que ça donne :
*son*
Quand on parle ou quand on chante,
on fait vibrer de l’air.
L’air est expulsé de nos poumons
au moment où l’on expire.
Au passage, il fait vibrer 2 petits muscles,
situés au sommet de la trachée,
baptisés à tort des cordes vocales.
Vous le voyez, ces muscles n’ont rien à voir
avec des cordes.
Cette vibration entraine la compression
et la détente des molécules qui constituent l’air.
Cette vibration se propage ensuite
dans la gorge et dans bouche,
des résonateurs qui vont façonner la voix.
Allez on réécoute le scribe…
*son*
Vous vous rendez compte ?
une dictée confinée depuis 3 000 ans… quelle capsule !
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également revoir les vidéos précédentes
en cliquant sur le côté droit.
J’en fais une nouvelle chaque jour.
Et pour être sûr de n’en rater aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
A demain !